et
notre envie de thé politique ce matin
c'est yann penser à bonjour bonjour rien
d'être avec nous porte parole et
directeur de campagne du candidat
communiste où tous les plaisirs fabien
roussel et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes tournée intervient en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest france bonjour stéphane
bonjour bonjour on commence évidemment
par l ukraine il ya une brosse à cesser
le feu ce matin mario paul c'est ce qui
a été annoncé par les rudes pour
permettre l'évacuation des civils mais
les occidentaux restent prudents et on a
vu un nouveau revirement des russes qui
ne voient pas d'avancée finalement dans
les pourparlers entre le cren et la
russie alors qu'ils avaient dit le
contraire la veille le retrait militaire
du nord de l'ukraine pourtant promis n'a
pas eu lieu est-ce que la perspective
d'une issue diplomatique s'éloignent
selon vous en tout cas il me paraît
indispensable qu'il y ait une issue
diplomatique
les français comme l'ensemble des
européens ont évidemment raison d'être
prudent parce qu'on sait de quoi poutine
a été capable depuis le début de cette
offensive criminelle en ukraine donc
nous avons re en raison de de faire
preuve d'une vigilance absolue cela dit
si l'on va vers un cessez le feu c'est
évidemment tant mieux ce que je souhaite
surtout c'est que la france comme
l'ensemble des pays de l'europe puisse
être à l'initiative d'une offensive
diplomatique visant à construire une
conférence européenne qui soit une
conférence de paix et de sécurité
collective ce que nous souhaitons avec
fabien roussel c'est que cette
conférence puisse traiter de l'ensemble
des dossiers des litiges qui existent
aujourd'hui à l'échelle de l'europe pas
seulement de l'union européenne mais de
l'ensemble de l'europe qu'on puisse les
traiter et qu'on aille vers un traité
sécurité collective est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut aller plus loin encore
dans les sanctions je pense que nous
avons pris un certain nombre de
sanctions d'abord nous nous les avons
soutenus pour ce qui concerne fabien
roussel il a été sans ambiguïté
là-dessus nécessité absolue 10 les
poutines à la fois sur le plan
économique et sur le plan diplomatique
nous l'avons soutenu je pense que nous
avons pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives s'il faut aller plus loin
on le fera
c'est là qu'il faut être extrêmement
vigilant et il faut trouver le juste
équilibre qui permettent à la fois de
faire pression sur poutine et pour
autant de ne pas nous mettre des balles
dans le pied parce que si on fragilise
le pouvoir d'achat des français je ne
vois pas en quoi on règle
fondamentalement le problème est par
ailleurs cette guerre arrive dans une
situation où le pouvoir d'achat des
français est déjà un sujet extrêmement
sensible et où il est extrêmement
fragilisée notamment par l'augmentation
du prix des carburants et de l'énergie
on va évidemment continuer à parler du
pouvoir d'achat tout à l'heure mais deux
dernières questions sur sur la guerre en
ukraine est ce que vous iriez jusqu'à
dire comme yannick jadot que total est
complice de crimes de guerre en russie
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
total se comportent en profiteurs de
guerre depuis le départ parce que en
même temps qu'il y à la guerre en même
temps que le prix des carburants explose
total continue de verser des dividendes
absolument astronomique à ses
actionnaires vous rendez compte que
total va verser en 2022 7 milliards
d'euros à ses actionnaires soit un
milliard de plus qu'en 2021 c'est à dire
qu'avec la guerre et avec les
souffrances endurées notamment par les
français qui payent un carburant
extrêmement cher total enrichi davantage
ses actionnaires que l'année précédente
et nous faisons une proposition simple
avec fabien roussel en 2022 0 dividendes
pour les actionnaires de total 0
dividende c'est à dire des dividendes
taxés à 100% et cet argent sera rendue
aux automobilistes français qui
aujourd'hui ont la gorge nouée parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir du
fait du prix des carburants est ce qu'au
delà total toutes les entreprises qui se
trouvent en françaises qui se trouvent
en russie et ce qu'elles doivent arrêter
toutes leurs activités toutes affaires
cessantes et le peuvent-elles à chaque
fois qu'on prend des sanctions il faut
se demander si elles sont utiles
imaginons demain par exemple qu'au chant
quitte la russie on va se retrouver avec
des milliers de salariés d'auchan aux
russes qui vont se retrouver au chômage
en quoi est-ce que ça règle le problème
pourquoi est-ce que donc je n'y suis pas
favorable
parce que tout cela n'aura qu'une seule
conséquence de susciter en russie une
haine des français une haine des
occidentaux et tout cela va renforcer
encore un peu plus le pouvoir de poutine
donc des sanctions qui conduisent à
produire l'exact inverse de ce qu on
souhaite je n'y suis pas favorable
et donc ça ne me paraît pas être une
mesure pertinente dans l'actualité à
saint paul et mick mc kinsey on va
évidemment parler un rapport sénatorial
porté par eliane assassi cayla
présidente du groupe communiste y cieux
sénat a pointé le recours excessif ces
cabinets de conseil privé notamment
durant la dernière année de ce
quinquennat près d'un milliard de
dépenses l'année dernière le
gouvernement a fait une conférence de
presse hier pour s'expliquer pour se
justifier il dit qu'il n'a rien à cacher
qu'il a fait toute la transparence ils
vous ont convaincu les ministres n'ont
d'abord je voudrais commencer par dire
un grand merci à eliane assassi et lui
tirer un coup de chapeau ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui se met beaucoup en avant
c'est souvent comme ça avec les
communistes mais c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille beaucoup et si elle n'avait
pas été là si elle n'avait pas fait avec
évidemment l'ensemble de ses collègues
ce travail d' enquête eliane assassi
présidente du groupe communiste au sénat
personne n'aura entendu parler de ces
cabinets de conseils parce qu'évidemment
le gouvernement ne se vantait pas
d'avoir recours à ces cabinets de
conseil comme d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de gouvernements précédents et
donc ce travail de transparence qui a
été effectuée par le sénat ce qui montre
d'ailleurs que le sénat a un rôle
extrêmement utile dans notre démocratie
ce travail là il a été fait et c'est
grâce à à eliane assassi et ses
collègues que ces réalités ont pu être
ont pu être pardon mise à jour cette
affaire elle est scandaleuse plus d'un
milliard d'euros qui ont été investis
dans ces cabinets de conseils pour faire
le travail que l'administration aurait
dû faire moi je suis attaché un principe
simple c'est à l'administration de faire
le travail de l'administration et il y
as derrière tout ça une forme de
délitement de démantèlement de l'état de
démantèlement de la république qui moi
me révulse avec fabien roussel nous
avons profondément confiance dans
l'administration dans la capacité de
l'administration à faire face aux
problèmes plus aucun recours à la cause
et privés
terminer c'est écrit dans notre
programme et ça fera d'ailleurs des
économies parfois on nous demande
comment on finance notre programme le
meilleur moyen pour financer notre
programme c'est d'arrêter la gabegie et
notamment d'arrêter le recours au
cabinet de conseil c'est à l'état de
faire le travail de l'état c'est à
l'administration de faire le travail de
l'administration et tout ça s'inscrit
dans une logique globale chez makro qui
est une logique de méfiance de défiance
vis-à-vis des services de l'état il faut
faire l' inverse il faut revaloriser
l'état dans une république forte on a
besoin d'un état fort et on a besoin
d'avoir confiance dans l'administration
et il ya un deuxième sujet qui est
fondamental qu'est la question de
l'optimisation fiscale
on peut pas continuer l'état ne peut pas
continuer de signer des contrats avec
des boîtes qui se paie le luxe de ne pas
payer d'impôts en france
il était dans le de labouheyre enfin
c'est quand même invraisemblable et
fabien roussel est le seul candidat à
avoir posé cette question de l'évasion
et de l'optimisation fiscale dans cette
campagne c'est 80 milliards d'euros au
moins qui partent en fumée chaque année
vous voulez mettre fin au recours à des
cabinets privés par par par l'état et
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose d'une pratique existe
depuis très longtemps qui peut être
aussi utile dans certains cas est ce
qu'on n'a pas intérêt à revenir à une
plus juste mesure c'est à dire encadrer
les choses là ce que pointe le rapport
sénatorial c'est une dérive c'est les
montants qui sont très importants mais
cette pratique là elle est pas en soi
scandaleux sin qu'on me fasse à ce
moment là la démonstration que les
cabinets de conseils ça faire des choses
que l'état ne sait plus faire et si
c'est délicat et si c'était le cas ça
prouverait qu'on a trop dépensé l'état
et qu'on a au contraire besoin de
renforcer la fonction publique de
renforcer notre administration mais à
force de démanteler l'ena à force de
taper sur la fonction publique on en
arrive à une perte de compétences du
service public et c'est un problème qui
est réel et auquel il faut
impérativement remédier j'ajoute un
élément quand vous voyez que des gens
qui ont fait de grandes écoles des
polytechniciens
travail pour ces cabinets de conseil ont
leur à payer leurs études non seulement
on leur à payer leurs études mais en
plus de ça ils ont été payés
refaire leurs études et derrière ils
vont travailler dans des cabinets de
conseil qui ne payent pas d'impôts en
france enfin vous imaginez où on en est
à quel niveau de gabegie on en est
arrivé ces gens arnaque l'état
j'entendais l'autre jour comment vous
faites c'est à dire j'en voudrais je
vous fais des études dans des hautes
écoles publiques vous ne pouvez pas
trouver de veine est pris d'abord vous
devez 10 ans à l'état c'est le signe ac
vous c'est le contrat que vous signez et
dans sa liste toujours glissé le
toujours qu'il devait rembourser il faut
veiller effectivement à ce que ceux qui
n'ont pas rempli leur engagement
décennal rembourse parce qu'ils n'ont
pas réalisé leur association aujourd'hui
c'est toujours le cas ici il faut
vérifier que ce soit toujours bien le
cas mais surtout des noms mais on a pas
moins jolie dit quand on a fait
polytechnique derrière on ne travaille
pas pour des cabinets de conseil qui
arnaquent l'état tout ça donne quand
même à un sentiment de 2,2 de révolte
profond vis-à-vis de ce qui est en train
de se passer j'entendais l'autre jour le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent qui disait il faut avoir recours
au cabinet de conseil avec parcimonie
mais enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'il faut arnaquer l'état
avec parcimonie enfin pour ou on en
arrive je pense que nous avons besoin de
responsables politiques d'un président
de la république qui retrouve le sens de
l'état du respect de l'état du respect
qui traduit en revanche que le président
de la république a perdu le sens de
l'état quand on a recours à des cabinets
de conseil qui arnaquent l'état en
faisant de l'optimisation fiscale en
faisant un travail que l'administration
est capable de faire on perd le sens de
l'état a besoin de retrouver ce sens de
l'état et ce sens de l'intérêt ce
sillage cas par les scandales d'état
comme le font certains gorille jc oui
c'est un scandale et à moi je suis pas
dans une logique complotistes je ne dis
pas qu'il y a une espèce de complot qui
s'est tramé jeudi qu'il y a des gens qui
ont théorisé le fait que l'état était un
poids dont il fallait se débarrasser et
qui pensent que le privé est
systématiquement mieux que le service
public on a la preuve du contraire quand
vous voyez que pour faire la réforme des
apl qui qui qui quand même coûte très
cher pour beaucoup de ménages modestes
on a eu recours à mckinsey franchement
ça le président la république qui a
perdu le sens de l'état ou c'est
simplement qu'il n'a pas la vision
globale de ce qui se passe dans
l'ensemble de ces ministères s'il n'y a
pas un peu de ça non plus beau c'est
logique sait on nous reproche nous
parfois d'être disant que c'est
parfaitement conscient consul voulu
conscient conçu idéologique et les
pragmatiques c'est nous c'est nous parce
que demain au pouvoir en n'ayant plus
recours à ces cabinets de conseil en
s'appuyant sur l'administration nous
ferons faire des économies à l'état sur
la crise sanitaire ian brossât hier le
gouvernement a dévoilé le protocole pour
les journées électorales des 10 et 24
avril pas de jauge pas de masque
obligatoire dans les bureaux de vote
est-ce que vous soutenez ces mesures en
tout cas moi je suis évidemment
favorable est ce que tout le monde
puisse voter c'est normal j'ai jeu j'ai
vu que un débat montait pour savoir s'il
fallait permettre à tout le monde de
voter évidemment que tout le monde doit
avoir le droit de vote est positif c'est
constitutionnel on va pas empêcher des
gens de voter sous prétexte qu'ils sont
positifs en revanche moi je souhaiterais
c'est une proposition qu'avait fabien
roussel hier qu'il y ait des masques
ffp2 à disposition de l'ensemble des
électeurs à l'entrée des bureaux de vote
n'ont pas à la charge des collectivités
qui déjà payent beaucoup et ont des
finances exemple mais à la charge de
l'état sur votre programme on va parler
évidemment du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
préoccupation numéro un des français
vous voulez augmenter le smic pour
atteindre rapidement les 1500 euros net
par mois juste pour être clair
rapidement c'est à quelle échéance c'est
dès le mois de juin
commence à dire vous imposer le smic par
décret oui bon c'est l'une des seules
décisions que le gouvernement peut
prendre en matière de salaires et nous
sommes donc favorables à ce qu'il y ait
un vrai coup de pouce au smic il n'y a
pas eu de vrai coup de pouce au smic
depuis plusieurs années il ya eu des
augmentations qui sont des augmentations
légal mais pas de vrai coup de pouce au
smic on a besoin de donner de l'air aux
familles de l'air aux salariés français
et donc nous sommes favorables à un smic
à 1500 euros nets soit 1900 euros brut
j'insiste sur le brut parce que je vois
beaucoup de deux candidats qui propose
d'augmenter les salaires par des baisses
de cotisations sociales c'est le cas de
zemmour c'est le cas de macron c'est le
cas de le pen c'est le cas de pécresse
un peu le programme commun de tous les
candidats de droite et d'extrême droite
nous ce que nous disons c'est qu'on a
besoin d'augmenter les salaires mais
augmenter aussi les cotisations sociales
parce que si vous baissez les
cotisations sociales vous ruiner la
sécurité sociale et nous allons nous
retrouver demain en france comme aux
états unis avec des gens qu'ils devront
rendre leur maison pour pouvoir se faire
soigner nous ne voulons pas de ce modèle
là nous voulons des salaires mais nous
voulons aussi de l'hôpital des retraites
bref tout ce qui va avec les cotisations
vous augmentez les salaires et les
cotisations sociales vous bien sûr que
les entreprises pourront tous de suivre
notamment les petites c'est une vraie
question et ya deux catégories
d'entreprises ya évidemment de très
grosses entreprises en parlait total
tout à l'heure et donc celle là ils ont
les tpe il ya aussi des petites
entreprises et pour les petites
entreprises nous proposons deux choses
d'abord nous proposons que les aides
publiques de l'état soient concentrés
sur les petites entreprises aujourd'hui
l'état est tout le monde les grosses
comme les petites nous disons que il
faut concentrer les aides sur les pme et
les tpe et deuxièmement nous proposons
une banque publique qui puisse prêter
par des prêts bonifiés de l'argent aux
petites entreprises quand je dis un prêt
bonifié ça veut dire que la banque vous
prête 100 euros et que sur ces 100 euros
vous n'aurez en bourse et que 80 c'est à
dire des prêts à taux négatif autrement
dit aider les petites entreprises les
artisans les commerçants les
agriculteurs les exploitants agricoles
également à faire des investissements or
aujourd'hui malheureusement les banques
ne leur prêtent pas ou alors leur
prêtent à des taux qui sont trop élevés
donc augmentation du smic les autres
salaires qui sont situés un peu au
dessus du smic suivront bien sûr par le
biais d'une conférence salariale avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux que
nous organiserons dès les premières
semaines classe a sera plus tg insiste
sur un point l'augmentation des petites
retraites l'augmentation des salaires
bien sûr mais aussi l'augmentation des
petites retraites et nous disons que
nous ne voulons pas de retraite en
dessous de 1200 euros on a aujourd'hui
trop de retraités qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie et qui n'arrivent pas à
vivre dignement
mais juste un mot pour finir sur
l'augmentation des salaires vous êtes
aussi pour l'augmentation des salaires
de la fonction publique de combien et
est-ce que ça concerne les trois
fonctions publiques parce que vous dites
vous même les collectivités sont exemple
comment vous leur faites payer les
salaires de leurs argentin nous sommes
effectivement favorables une
augmentation des salaires de la fonction
publique prioritairement les petits
salaires je pense en particulier aux
catégories c'est ce qu'on a d'ailleurs
les plus vues pendant les différents
confinement qui ont été là qui ont fait
un travail difficile qui ont continué à
bosser alors même que la france était
pour une bonne part à la réception de
30% d'ici la fin du mandat donc lycée à
l'échelle de l'ensemble du mandat c'est
indispensable parce que le point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires a été gelé
depuis dix ans même si le gouvernement a
opportunément en pleine campagne annoncé
qu'ils seraient des gelées heureusement
qu'il ya quand même une élection
présidentielle tous les cinq ans c'est
bien le seul avantage d'être passé du
septennat au quinquennat mais surtout
il y as besoin de revaloriser ces
salaires alors vous me dites comment
notamment pour les collectivités locales
ça suppose de donner plus de dotations
aux collectivités locales de donner de
l'air financiers aux collectivités
locales or vous avez vu que dans le
programmes des manuels macron il y a 10
milliards d'euros d'économies sur le dos
des collectivités locales ce que dit
laurent saint martin mais c'est très
grave de à nouveau de fragiliser les
collectivités locales parce que derrière
on fragilise les services publics locaux
la réforme des retraites donc fabien
roussel président rétabli la la retraite
à 60 ans pour tout le monde à quelle
échéance ou à quel rythme vous faites ça
dès le début du quinquennat ou wii
progressivement c'est une mesure qu'il
faut prendre dès le début du quinquennat
parce que nous avons besoin de permettre
aux retraités enfin à ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie de bénéficier
du droit au repos à 60 ans si on a été
capable en 1981 en 80 avec françois
mitterrand et georges marchais de mettre
en place la retraite à 60 ans on doit
être capable de le faire aujourd'hui
alors que la france produit cinq fois
plus de richesses qu à l'époque cinq
fois plus de richesses qu à l époque et
donc bien sûr je l'assumé c'est pour
tout le monde sans critère de pénibilité
c'est à dire que
et seront à la retraite à 60 ans comme
nous qui travaillons guerre c'est
seulement avec les fonctions d'un peigne
personne ne vous obligera de partir en
retraite à 60 ans si vous souhaitez
travailler davantage vous aurez la
possibilité de travailler davantage
évidemment en revanche tous ceux qui le
souhaitent et c'est aux gens d'en juger
tous ceux qui le souhaitent auront la
possibilité de partir en retraite à 60
ans à taux plein à taux plein au bout de
37 annuités et demi c'était le cas avant
ça doit être le cas demain avec fabien
sait comment comment vous financer
l'ensemble de ces propositions
l'augmentation des salaires de la
fonction publique la réforme des
retraites vous vous créer de nouveaux
impôts comment comment vous équilibrer
les choses moi j'assume et nous assumons
avec fabien roussel mais ça coûte le fai
dont on a besoin je répondrai très
directement votre question mais je
répond d'abord à l'impressionnant parce
que nous avons besoin d'augmenter
globalement le budget de l'état parce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui trop de besoins qui
ne sont pas satisfaits donc augmentation
du budget de l'état 200 milliards
d'euros dès la première année c'est à
dire dès le budget 2011 23 c'est à dire
le budget que le nouveau président de la
république avec son gouvernement aura à
élaborer comment de deux manières
d'abord en procédant à un certain nombre
de remises en cause de dépenses qui
existaient qui n'existeront plus les
cabinets de conseil s'est terminé et
deuxièmement des recettes
supplémentaires et ça je l'assument donc
les impôts supplémentaires des impôts
supplémentaires sur les grosses
entreprises et sur les plus riches deux
exemples la taxation à la source des
multinationales mettre un terme à
l'évasion fiscale qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui 80 milliards d'euros nous
échappe parce qu'ils partent en fumée et
qu'ils partent vers des paradis fiscaux
et deuxièmement leur établissement par
exemple de l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune que nous proposons deux triplés
et qui rapportera 10 milliards d'euros
chaque année avant c'était 3 milliards
et demi on le triple ce sera 10
milliards d'euros mais plus profondément
sur notre vision globale je l'assumé
aussi je ne pense pas qu'on reconstruira
le pays et qu'on augmentera la valeur de
la france avec des français malheureux
notre slogan c'est la france des jours
heureux c'est le programme le plus
économique qui soit parce que on
permettra à la france de gagner de la
valeur de retrouver de la puissance si
les français sont en forme on ne remet
pas un pays à pied avec des français qui
ont la tête sous l'eau qui vont mal
qu'ils sont déprimés or c'est le cas de
la france aujourd'hui le moral des
ménages il n'est pas bon et donc à moral
des messages échangés du sud vient qui
disent que les français sont heureux
mais c'est vrai que le vent française se
porte très mal les françaises comment
vous faites pour la dette qui est
faramineuse par exemple on a joué les
dix ans des routards d'euros tête des
recettes nouvelles on a laissé on vous
réduirez la dette de la france nous au
final nous réduiront la dette de la
france parce que l'activité reprendra et
que des recettes nouvelles entreront
dans le budget de l'état sur la campagne
vous voyez la dynamique ces derniers
jours de jean luc mélenchon est ce que
l'argument du vote utile jean luc
mélenchon est en train de prendre
d'abord jean luc mélenchon lui même dit
qu'il n'est pas favorable au vote utile
dont je n'y suis pas prêt à cette
expression en tout cas je pense que dans
une démocratie il n'y a pas de vote
utile et de vote inutile il n'y a pas de
citoyens utile et de citoyens inutile il
n'y a pas d'idée utile et d'idées
minutes il y à des citoyens libres et
égaux en droits c'est la constitution
c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et les français
doivent se déterminer par rapport à leur
résister on a un candidat qui incarne la
gauche populaire la gauche républicaine
c'est fabien roussel il est par ailleurs
un candidat franc sincère et je pense
qu'on a besoin de cette incarnation
gauche jean luc mélenchon il incarne son
chemin nous incarnons le nôtre j'ai du
respect pour lui mais mon candidat c'est
fabien roussel précisément parce que il
incarne cette france qu'on a trop peu vu
ces dernières années trop peu entendue
ces dernières années c'est le seul
candidat de gauche à ne pas vivre en
région parisienne enfin l'un des seuls
et et je pense qu'on a besoin de ça on a
besoin de cette fraîcheur là que fabien
roussel incarne depuis le début et
d'ailleurs je note une dynamique des
soutiens qui qui qui nous arrive tous
les jours il n'est pas d'ailleurs
uniquement le candidat du parti
communiste il est soutenu par marie
noëlle lienemann par emmanuel maurel et
y en aura d'autres dans les jours qui
viennent donc il y à quelque chose qui
est en train de
vous avez des ralliements dernier
absolument et puis surtout vous verrez
bien mais surtout ce que je dis aux
électeurs ces données nous de la force
nous en ferons quelque chose d'utile on
parlait de mckinsey tout à l'heure c'est
les communistes qui ont révélé
l'augmentation des retraites agricoles
c'est andré chassaigne député communiste
à chaque fois qu'on donne un peu de
pouvoirs aux communistes ils en font
quelque chose d'utile donc cette leçon
la retenait là excusez moi d'insister
mais il fait une très belle campagne il
va il va finir va probablement faire un
score très honorable
vous n'aurez pas des regrets si ce score
empêché jean luc mélenchon lettre au
second tour alors que entre le programme
de votre programme et l'avenir en commun
il ya quand même beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de similitudes les deux sont très
proches d'abord il ya des divergences je
pense notamment à la question ce qui
n'est pas négligeable qui est la
question du nucléaire quand même aussi
beaucoup de proximité heureusement qu'à
gauche et de la proximité entre les
différents candidats ça vaut pour les
autres candidats aussi et du coup on
aurait pu vous n'auriez pas les regrets
s'il faudra le bon score de fabien
roussel je vois dans les empêcher jean
luc mélenchon que je vois dans les
enquêtes d'opinion c'est que nous
progressons ensemble et pas les uns au
détriment des autres nous progressons
ensemble il ya deux dynamique à gauche
dans cette campagne et à jean luc
mélenchon bien sûr qu'ils partaient plus
haut que nous et il ya fabien roussel et
donc ces deux dynamiques elles existent
et elles ne se mangent pas l'une l'autre
il progresse ensemble et donc tant mieux
parce que ça renforce au final la gauche
et si un candidat de gauche et au
deuxième tour il aura bien besoin de
reports de voix et donc en l'occurrence
tout ça crée une dynamique pouzilhac a
voté pour jean luc mélenchon semble
alors on a voté pour n'importe quel
candidat de gauche qui arrivera au
deuxième tour et donc tout ça crée une
dynamique positive pour l'ensemble de la
gauche est cependant je pense que c'est
cela qu'il faut vous pourriez participer
à un gouvernement de jean luc mélenchon
malgré vos divergences on l'avait dit
sur un sujet comme on en voit dès lors
que la gauche gagne il va bien falloir
que tout le monde travaille ensemble et
donc ça vaut pour jean luc mélenchon
comme pour n'importe quel autre candidat
d'ouges mons quoi évidemment c'est que
ce soit fabien roussel qui arrive en
tête s'il n'y a pas de candidat de
gauche au second tour comme les sondages
l'annoncent pour le moment tant ce ne
sont que des sondages et ils sont à
prendre avec des précautions mais en cas
de second tour entre emmanuel macron et
rinne le pen vous appeler à voter pour
lui d'abord j'en ai ras-le-bol qu'on me
parle de deuxième tour avant les
journalistes
jean luc mélenchon il a dit qu'il allait
consulter sa base avant de prendre une
décision est ce que ça sera pareil pour
le parti continue et nous nous avons
toujours pris nos responsabilités
lorsque l'extrême droite
était au deuxième tour et nous avons
toujours dit qu'il faut battre l'extrême
droite donc nous ne changerons pas de
devoir danser mais j'étais votre base
vont passer un appel à battre à face que
c'est l'évidence même et est chez nous
ça ne fait pas tout le troisième tour la
législative
fabien roussel souhaitait un accord
avant le 10 avril ça va être compliqué
pour l'accord disais allez ça va sans
doute être bon peu chaud mais après en
tout cas nous maintenons l'idée qui a
besoin que la gauche se retrouvent aux
élections législatives y aura un accord
avec je le souhaite pour qui un accord
il faut pas que nous sinon c'est moi
avec tout le monde nous le souhaitons
ardemment et donc mon souhait le plus
ardent c'est que nous parvenions à un
accord avant le 10 avril dans l'idéal
après le 10 avril si on n'y arrive pas
merci à vous merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous à directeur de campagne et
porte-parole de ventre candidats fabien
roussel
[Musique]